INEVITABILITY, RELATIONS BETWEEN
RUSSIA AND UKRAINE WILL
NORMALIZE.
UKRAINIANS MAY THINK DIFFERENTLY
ABOUT THAT.
>> FRED, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> WE'RE JOINED BY A UKRAINIAN
MEMBER OF PARLIAMENT.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY, I KNOW THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT AND RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS, ESPECIALLY
VLADIMIR PUTIN, TELL A LOT OF
LIES.
ARE THERE ANY IN PARTICULAR YOU
HEARD THEM SAYING RIGHT NOW THAT
YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO?
>> I JUST SEE THAT THEY BELIEVE
IN THEIR OWN PROPAGANDA BECAUSE
THEY LIVE IN THEIR OWN WORLD.
RUSSIA WANTS TO SHOW IT'S A
SUPERPOWER, BUT THE GDP OF
RUSSIA IS THE SAME AS THE STATE
OF TEXAS.
IT DOES HAVE OIL, GAS.
THIS COUNTRY WANTS TO BLACKMAIL
THE WHOLE WORLD, TO THREATEN THE
WESTERN CIVILIZATION, BUT THE
WEST IS MUCH STRONGER.
IT SHOULDN'T BE COWERING THAT
THE WEST IS STRONGER.
YOU KNOW, PUTIN UNDERSTANDS ONLY
THE LANGUAGE OF FORCE.
I TOOK TO THE STUDIO A PIECE OF
RUSSIAN JET, IT WAS SHUT DOWN BY
OUR MILITARY IN MARCH.
IN THE KYIV REGION.
AT THE SAME TIME, RUSSIANS WERE
SELLING THE PROPAGANDA THAT
UKRAINE DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING
LEFT IN THEIR AIRCRAFT, NO
DEFENSE SYSTEM.
JUST FLY THERE, KILL PEOPLE.
NOTHING HAPPENS.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
WE SHOT THEM, AND WE ARE
DEFENDING OUR COUNTRY, PUSH THEM
AWAY FROM THE NORTH OF THE
COUNTRY, WE'RE PLANNING THE
OPERATION TO COUNTERATTACK TO
THE SOUTH, AND OF COURSE, TO
STAND, YOU KNOW, AND DEFEND
DONBAS AREA, DONETSK AND
LUHANSK.
WE NEED THOSE HEAVY WEAPONS.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE, YOUR PEOPLE IN
THIS PIECE AND VIDEO TOLD THAT
IT'S A LOT OF HARD UTILRY THAT
RUSSIANS ARE USING.
WE NEED AT LEAST TO GET CLOSER
WITH THE NUMBERS OF ARTILLERY
THAT WE USE.
AND THEN, THEIR MORALE IS REALLY
LOW.
OUR MORALE IS MUCH HIGHER.
THEY WILL FLEE, BUT WE NEED
THOSE WEAPONS ON THE GROUND.
>> RIGHT, AND THE UNITED STATES
HAS BEEN PROVIDING A LOT OF
HEAVY WEAPONRY AND A LOT OF
MONEY.
I KNOW A LOT OF OTHER COUNTRIES
IN THE WEST HAVE TALKED A BIG
GAME BUT NOT ACTUALLY PROVIDED
THE WEAPONRY THEY HAVE PROMISED.
MOST NOTABLY, VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY, THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE, CALLED OUT OLAF SCHOLZ,
THE CHANCELLOR OF GERMANY, THIS
WEEK.
WHAT COUNTRIES NEED TO STEP UP
MORE?
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU THINK THE
U.S. NEEDS TO KEEP DOING MORE.
AND THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT
IS.
IT'S ONE OF THE FEW THINGS THAT
OUR CONGRESS VOTES ON IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY.
WHAT OTHER COUNTRIES NEED TO
STEP UP MORE?
>> I THINK THAT LEADERSHIP OF
AMERICA IS CRUCIAL, BECAUSE
EVERYONE IS LOOKING TO AMERICA
AS A LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD.
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, SORT OF SAY
OKAY, AMERICANS ARE GIVING THAT
MUCH WEAPONS.
WE'LL NOT GIVE MORE, BUT AT
LEAST IT WON'T BE MUCH LESS.
SO GREAT BRITAIN IS BACKING US
UP AS WELL.
AND OF COURSE, GERMANY AND
FRANCE WE EXPECT COULD DO MORE,
AS THE LEADERS IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION.
BUT FIRST OF ALL, I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK FOR BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR THE $40 BILLION THAT WAS
VOTED IN THE CONGRESS, AND I'M
HERE, I CAME HERE WITH A
DELEGATION OF UKRAINIAN
PARLIAMENT TO MEET OUR
COUNTERPARTS, BOTH IN SENATE AND
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES TO
THANK THEM FOR THIS, AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE MONEY THAT WERE
ALLOCATED ARE BEING TRANSFERRED
TO THE WEAPONS THAT WE NEED.
AND THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HAVE A LOT OF TIME BEFORE THE
WINTER, AND PUTIN IS JUST
WAITING SO WEST WILL FORGET
ABOUT US, AND THEN THE WINTER,
THE GAS PRICES, SO HE WILL BE
JUST, YOU KNOW, SORT OF WAITING
FOR THE WEST TO BLINK FIRST.
>> RIGHT.
WE HAVEN'T FORGOTTEN ABOUT IT
HERE, BUT I KNOW OTHER NEWS
CHANNELS HAVE MOVED ON.
LAST TIME YOU AND I SPOKE WAS IN
UKRAINE.
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF DESIGNATED RUSSIA
AS A STATE SPONSOR OF TERROR.
I KNOW THAT YOU MET WITH HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI AND YOU SAY
YOU HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION WITH
HER ABOUT THAT.
WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT TO YOU AND
ARE YOU FRUSTRATED PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS NOT TAKEN THAT STEP
YET?
>> THANK YOU FOR THIS QUESTION,
AND WE DID HAVE A GOOD
CONVERSATION WITH NANCY PELOSI,
AND SHE TOTALLY AGREES THAT IT'S
A GOOD STEP TO PUT FORWARD.
OF COURSE, I UNDERSTAND IT
SHOULD BE PUT IN THE RIGHT WAY,
THE RIGHT DEFINITIONS TO TALK TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE.
BUT SHE SUPPORTS IT.
AND ACTUALLY, AS I UNDERSTOOD
FROM THE MEETINGS IN THE SENATE,
THERE WILL BE A VOTE FOR THE
RESOLUTION, MIGHT BE A VOTE, I
WOULD SAY MIGHT BE A VOTE FOR
THE RESOLUTION NEXT WEDNESDAY IN
THE SENATE.
AND I REALLY HOPE IT WILL GET
MOVING.
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT, BECAUSE
THEN OTHER COUNTRIES, ESPECIAL